last question today David is democracy
intrinsically or inherently good if it
leads to bad outcomes in terms of the
people that are elected and what they do
this is a great question that the scope
of which could be the subject of a week
of shows but let's think through a few
of the issues here I've read quite a bit
of Plato and Plato Socrates hated
democracy in in many senses Socrates
used the analogy of a ship if you
imagine a big ship out on the ocean and
the analogy Socrates used was if you're
bringing a ship out to sea should
everybody get a say in deciding where
the ship goes anybody anybody at all
right full total democracy everybody
gets to say or do we want to limit that
choice that influence to those who have
some understanding of ships and
seafaring and the weather and whatever
else would be relevant to getting a ship
out there so the the sort of overarching
question is why do we let anyone decide
who should run our country the idea
being that effective democracy is a
skill and the people directing that that
democracy need to understand it
otherwise you're going to have people
making bad decisions it's important to
consider if that logic is is influential
in your mind it's important to consider
a couple of things number one the
founding fathers of the United States
valued democracy such that they said
there shall be no test for voting so we
can disagree with that but that is the
system we have and without changing that
we are going to not have tests for
voting period but it's important to
consider if we imagine getting rid of
that and saying hey it should be ok to
have tests to participate in democracy
democracy instead of what in other words
what are the alternative systems a real
concern about democracy is that the
people will democratically elect morons
we're dealing with that right now but
the idea is that at least democracy
gives you
the opportunity to remove those morons
if people wake up whereas an
authoritarian dictator could be just as
bad as a democratically elected [ __ ] or
authoritarian but far more difficult to
remove the counterpoint being well the
people can choose to remove a leader and
they can choose to democratically elect
a despot who will take power and will
not give it up but at least there is
some mechanism or apparatus enshrined in
how government operates for their
removal now there's another layer to
this is it a democracy if not everybody
votes is that actually a democracy
because if people don't vote then you
have a democracy on paper which is
actually controlled by a select group of
people that could be because people
choose not to vote it could be because
of voter suppression where people try to
vote but their vote is ultimately not
counted the reality is there's no pure
democracy if 60% of the population votes
for one president and 40% voted for
somebody else
those 40% do not have a representative
of their interests the president is
supposed to represent all Americans of
course but the truth is if you didn't
vote for the president you do not have a
representative in the Oval Office that
you have selected my answer where I kind
of come to this is that democracy is not
inherently good and inherently being the
key word but actual democracy does
promote a certain degree of stability
and accountability that worse systems do
not does that mean that democracy always
works out perfectly no does it mean that
democracy is not vulnerable to attacks
on that mechanism that elects our
leaders obviously not look at what
happened in 2016 and what we should all
be working towards is the most educated
and aware electorate possible because
that is a direct way to make democracy
function better for everybody and
unfortunately when half the country
doesn't even vote and some significant
percentage of those who do vote are
voting and making decisions from a place
of ignorance
that's a really bad thing and the
results are exactly what we're seeing
right now send me your thoughts on
democracy being inherently or
intrinsically good we've got a great
bonus show today I'll tell you about all
the wacky stuff that's been going on
this week behind the scenes the holiday
schedule and much more
patreon Membership YouTube membership
three ways to get access to the bonus
show we'll speak to you then